then we will select the values of gamma and beta that correspond to this low cost value and run the circuit one last
time now using the sampler this is the result of me running the cobal Optimizer with my initial guesses here you can see
that the value of the cost function over the iterations performed starts off a little wonky and it goes up and down but
then it settles to a low value we will use these last gamma and beta values that correspond to the minimum cost
function evaluation to run the circuit one last time and Sample the bit string that will give us the max
cut now using our optimized values for the gamas and betas we will run the circuit one last time to find the best
possible bit string using sampler I listed the specific values that I am using here but remember when you try
your hand at this or even just rerun the same tutorial notebook these values might change slightly now we will run
our optimized circuit with these values and find our candidate solution to our Max cut problem if you were using
sessions that is no longer necessary since we are just running one last job now we we will finally look at the
postprocessing stage and finding our final solution first let's plot all of
the possible combinations of nodes which we have converted into bit strings as a histogram you can see right away that
when I ran it I found four Solutions and highlighted those in purple that are more probable than any other solution
the highest and thus most probable bit string solution is 0 1 01 please note the order of the cubits
is reversed in the plot looking at the most probable solution we note that the nodes 0 and three are grouped together
and similarly for nodes 1 2 and four we can finally plot the most likely
bit string back as a graph and remember the bit string simply corresponds to the node numbers and if they are included
marked with a one or not included marked with a zero in our grouping when we draw the cut now we can see with our eyes the
approximate line for the best cut which just represents the ideal grouping of all five nodes which I've drawn here one
thing I want to spend some time discussing here however is the fact that the correct solution is not unique
because of the symmetry of this graph there are multiple correct Solutions instead of having nodes 0 and three be
inside the cut we could have nodes 2 and four be included and you can see that all I had to do was rotate my cut to
include these new points this solution of five Remains the Same
let's take another look at the histogram and the four most likely solutions for a minute the last two solutions are the
ones that we just plotted and they are equally correct but that's not all we could also reverse the coloring for all
of the correct Solutions and this time we just think of the nodes as being inside versus outside the cut on the
previous slide we identified two unique correct Solutions but there are actually two more solutions one corresponding to
the opposite of each of those see how here where I drew the remaining two solutions all I did was reverse the
colors now the only problem is that the algorithm actually didn't find or identify this fourth last solution as
being one of the top four most probable answers it was the fifth the fourth solution that the algorithm identified
is actually Incorrect and if you were to draw it you would see that that solution only has four cuts and since the others
have five and four is clearly less than five this is obviously wrong the point here
is that this is an approximate algorithm it is not infallible and it is not correct 100% of the time you do have to
employ some of your own knowledge and understanding to sanity check the solutions it is worth highlighting that
this error can arise from several places it could be the approximate nature of the algorithm itself and the small
number of layers that I chose to employ it could be a finite sampling error and this could be reduced if I increase the
number of shots in my experiment or it could be a readout error since the fourth Real solution is only off by one
bit the reason I'm pointing out all of these possibilities is because this is what it takes to fully become a
practitioner of quantum Computing you need to understand the performance of the hardware and how this can contribute
to certain types of errors and how to correct for them however let's not forget that there
were 32 possible Brit bit string Solutions and that the four real solutions were included in the top five
best candidates and I only use two layers to find this in general if I want to increase my chances of finding the
best Max cut every time I would increase the layer depth there are some subtleties to this but that's for a later
episode now I'm going to let you try your hand at this yourself but this time you're going to use 100
cubits so if we start by drawing our 100 Cubit graph you can see that it is no longer straightforward or even possible
to eyeball where the max cut would occur there are simply too many possibilities to be able to pick it out by hand but
solving this problem using qoa is still totally doable and you can follow the exact same workflow that we used for 5
cubits I'm about to send you off on your own and charge you with trying to do this experiment but before I do let's
summarize recall that the six steps of any qaoa job are as follows one defining
a cost hamiltonian such that its ground state encodes the solution to the optimization problem two defining a
mixer hamiltonian three constructing the operator's corresponding to the exponentiated
hamiltonians four building the circuit it will consist of the initial ground state of the mixer and alternating
repeated layers of the cost function and the evolution under the mixer Hamilton iians five prepare an initial State and
use classical Computing techniques to optimize the parameters six run the circuit measure output bit strings
looking for the most probable solution now some things to note here I
used optimization level three for my 5 Cubit example but that maybe wasn't necessary and the right answer could
still be returned most of the time at a lower level of optimization because the circuit depth was fairly low for the 5
Cubit case but for the 100 cubits and a large circuit depth you almost certainly will need the highest level of
optimization to find the right answer also keep in mind that one of the most challenging parts of a typical utility
scale workflow is the mapping stage and finding a graph that corresponds well to IBM's heavy hex topology if you were
doing this work from scratch that's undoubtedly where you would devote much of your time for now this part has been